[Music]
foreign
krista thank you for joining in 20
minute leaders this is so great
thank you i'm so happy to be here it's a
lot of fun such a pleasure for me
uh biotech leadership startups
let's just get started tell me a little
bit about yourself and and how you got
to where you are today
uh so my journey is very interesting i i
tell a lot of people that my motto
is not all who wander are lost because i
have always
meandered a little bit in my career and
i tell a lot of people
early career mid-career or late career
but that's okay
and we're in a time in in history where
i think that
more and more people have multiple
careers during their career and i think
that's
that's a really important piece so i
started out
um working on communication plans and
working on ways to help companies be
more effective
usually in a time of crisis and then i
moved into
startups in the mid 90s i i helped a
startup startup
which was very different from how it is
today i remember the first time we used
email
it was this really big deal in the
office i remember the first time
that um monster came on board i want to
say with mid maybe 96
97 and it was this this big deal
and you know in terms of of careers and
values and how to find people
and how to bring talent on board um so
that's been that was the theme i i
started with crisis management i moved
into
startups and then i started to do some
turnaround work as well
so a little bit about crisis management
what is what is what does that mean
crisis management
yes so at the time um i did some work
for a company so
i've also meandered between being a
full-time employee and a consultant
so at the time i was a consultant i was
i was actually
finishing my undergrad i worked full
time as i was finishing my undergrad and
one of my clients um they had an issue
with their product
where i won't get into details but but
they
they created a product that was
chemically based
and viscosity changed to the point where
they were admitting gases and then they
had to create a report they had to go
report to epa and the scientists this
was for the head of r d at the time and
and it's like
very um demoralized i don't know how
else to describe it that sounds like a
strong word but they were very
you know it's when you work on something
for a really long time in r d
and then one little thing happens you
always know in the back of your mind
that there's a risk for that
but until it happens you don't know how
it's going to work out
so that is one piece of that crisis
management where you have a
deep bench of talent that's been working
on something that's critically important
for the organization
something bad happens everybody put it
in the risk management plan but once it
starts you you
you go through your mitigations and your
your steps but you have humans you have
to be thinking about too
and you have to lead them um so that
they have the space to react
and to work with the problems on their
own as individuals you need to keep them
cohesive
as a group and you need them to stay
focused on the vision and the mission
what you're trying to do
to say this is this is now the step
forward we still have a plan
let's stay aligned let's let's get
moving forward
so where do you so having seen different
crises unfold
and helping companies through them what
do you see are some of the pitfalls
or what are some of the things that
would enable a company to power through
a difficult crisis versus not power
through and i'm sure you've seen both
ends of the spectrum
i have um leadership i know that sounds
like your
typical plain vanilla garden variety
answer but it's
it's true um typically so there's a
couple ways that companies or teams can
get into crisis
it's either what's going on externally
and your ability to manage that
internally or what's going on internally
your ability to manage that and then
what's going on internally
and your ability to make sure that the
external factors either don't infect it
make it worse
or you can actually turn it into
something that could strengthen the team
and strengthen the organization and help
again help them move forward so i think
that there are a variety of factors that
contribute to that crisis management
we're seeing a lot of it now
today it's a great example of what what
many companies are doing what many small
businesses have to do yeah and um and so
that that leadership
really matters and and i want to say
also leadership doesn't mean you have to
be a ceo
you know we have a lot of parents right
now they're really flexing their muscles
yeah we have community leaders we have
organizers we have people who have an
idea
and then they decide they're going to do
something about that idea
and now they have people they've stirred
passion and they stirred energy
about and now those people are following
them well
now we have a leader and we have a
leader leading in crisis who can keep
people motivated
focused passionate useful people are
feeling more
valued and useful that's a lot of what
it takes to
to and you see that with turning around
businesses that's what it takes
definitely okay so let's move on to
biotech and tell me
from you know that you're the scientist
and you what is it about biotech that
excites you and how is it different
this biotech industry from you know the
regular industries that we hear
on techcrunch every day or forbes or
whatever
i love that question i love that
question even even my students when they
first come in so i teach
at northeastern biotech enterprise and
and they're masters students and they're
scientists i have some business students
who come in too
and and they come in and uh and they
always say
uh i'm not a business person i'm only a
scientist
you know and that's the question i pose
them is let's talk about what's
different first
when it comes to biotech so if nothing
else you can value and appreciate the
uniqueness of the industry
so i've been in a few other industries
this is my favorite one
and there are a couple of reasons behind
that the first
reason is because you're you're doing
unusual and miraculous work
uh in in biopharma or the medicine
aspect you're doing it for a patient
um either for diagnosing staging
screening
therapeutics that's for a patient
there's a human that's going to benefit
because work that you're doing in
in biofuels in environmental
and you know there's all sorts of
biotech out there and you're taking
something that's
that has a biology base uh something
has something related to life and then
you're bringing it into hopefully
improve
life right so how amazing is that so
biotech so different and
the second piece that i like a lot and
folks i think in high tech and other
other industries
will appreciate this is you cannot
sell your product until you've proven
it works the way you say it's going to
work and it's safe
so those i'm grossly simplifying it but
those are the two pieces that really
make it different so
you know i remember working in uh so
i've worked in financial management i've
worked in engagement management i've
worked in consulting a whole
host of other things high tech you know
how many people in high tech we all know
things get released
sure maybe they shouldn't have been
released at the time they were released
maybe you're almost through some kind of
user acceptance testing but but you've
released it and then comes all the fixes
for the bugs
that can't happen in medicine or at
least we try to reduce that as much as
possible
yeah that's one of the things i'm really
curious about you know so i'm a software
engineer
and i and i really enjoy working on on
user user interfacing products where
i get to release i get to release
something every day and you know
sometimes it
breaks and that's also fun because i get
to learn from it breaking
but it sounds like in the biotech
industry that's not really a route that
i could
take uh you know just you know move fast
and break things the old facebook
moto what how do you how do you navigate
and balance this both agile lean startup
model
with a product that is has to really be
bulletproof
yes so um that's what the research is
about
once you've discovered something and
there's steps that you have to take and
that's where that
that discipline focus steps come to to
pass
because when you're looking to do
something with the human body you have
to remember that
the human body is smarter than we are
it's it's
if it's healthy it's more efficient than
we could ever be uh if it's not healthy
it's not as efficient and we might not
understand where the efficiencies are
broken down
and so whatever you do with it you know
we've all heard of that case where you
fix one thing and three other things
fam yeah yeah harder so in biotech
we're trying to not do that you know
they're they're large molecules which
means that um
the barrier to entry into a cell usually
needs a different mechanism in order to
make that
that work so there are you know we
discovered something we say oh
i think we have something you know we
work through different
models and different testing and then it
goes through
you know depending on what the therapy
is or what the what the diagnostic
choices
it goes to a very specific um discipline
and it goes through this
rigor because you want to be sure that
it is
safe you want to be sure it's doing what
you
expected to do and during the research
that's clinical trials clinical trials
research you start off small and then
and then you hit that milestone and you
go to the next trial
okay more people we're changing our dose
we're seeing what the tolerance is we're
seeing what the end points are you hit
that one
you hope and then you move in to the
final phase
um and again sometimes it's different
because if you're working in gene
therapy and you
you're changing people's genetic
composition
or or sometimes you're just using
something to drop it into something else
to then
attack something genetically uh but
but this is what the rigor is all about
and this is what a lot of scientists and
medical professionals are talking about
especially today when they're talking
about the rigor that's required for a
vaccine
for therapy you know even diagnostics
out there
yeah sure and it sounds like the life
cycle then
um from idea to product to selling
it's much longer than on many other
industries so you really need to have
partners that really accept that right i
mean i'm thinking
in in terms of investors or in terms of
of people that you bring on board
there has to be an understanding that
this is a marathon it's not a sprint and
it might take a few years until we
actually bring something out there
that's right and that's where the
science comes in because you know
science is science and many times you
might understand it
quite a bit and still something happens
that's unpredicted
many times a lot of things happens
that's unpredicted and that's how it
should be that's how you learn
that's how you understand the value of
your asset that's how you understand the
value it could have in humans or in
animals you know there's a lot of
companies biotech companies that provide
therapeutics for animals as well
so that's that's what that um that's
what the process is all about now i will
say
that it used to take 10 to 15 years in
order to develop
an asset and sometimes it still does
depending on the complexity and also
depending on the precedent because if
you're doing something
the first time ever there's a lot of
learning that takes place
we have a lot of instances now where
companies are coming together
to shorten some of that time frame or
they're using data
differently they're working with their
regulatory agencies to say
well if we can extrapolate data from
this particular study
or because of what this product did and
how significantly equivalent
our product is to that one are we able
to
um condense or are we able to combine or
are we able to make more efficient
some of these trials so that we can
still prove along the way
that it's safe and efficacious that it's
doing what it says
we expect it to do definitely not it's
it's so interesting
for me to be speaking both to to a
professor but at the same time an
entrepreneurs and the leader
so what are some of the things that as
you watch these you know young
hungry new upcoming leaders
and entrepreneurs and scientists walk
into your classroom what i mean you're
an educator it's not just you know
giving them information and having them
spit it out what are some of the mindset
that you're trying to instill in them as
they go through this journey of becoming
you know an entrepreneur later on or a
scientist later on
yeah i love that question because um i
really do view my job
from my professor job as uh
someone who's indoctrinating a lot of
the students right
yeah you know first and foremost it has
to be about the patients and that's what
i talk about
every step of the way and and the joke
that a few of us say in industry is that
if it's not for the patient then it's
just the science project
and that's not meant to be a pejorative
uh
with science projects because those are
really important that's what happens
with
discovery but in this business if you're
in the biotech business
as a business your end goal is to get it
to a patient
and to impact that patient is positively
right as possible so that's first and
foremost
the second piece is making sure that our
scientists have
enough business understanding so that he
or she
can can raise their value raise their
competitiveness
raise their imaginative views of what
they're capable of doing
and then their realistic views of what
they're capable of doing uh
in in our industry this most of my
students are between the ages of
28 and 32 years old a lot of them have
already started an industry
or they've completed higher education in
a different country or even in this one
they've come over because they want to
advance into a professional master
science and biotech
biotechnology so i'm working with
already with students that have that
background
typically very deep in lab and they're
trying to say
how do i at least learn more about what
i need to learn about
and my whole thing is let me
indoctrinate you so that it's about i
love it
let me make sure that you understand
that um what
is required that as you're making your
upstream as you as you're doing
all the important incredible work here
that you're thinking about a regulatory
pathway you're thinking about the
medical affairs team you're thinking
about medical science liaisons who have
to be
talking to key opinion leaders in
industry you're thinking about
what it takes to get your product
through a clinical trial
there are some so even now in my company
we
look at a lot of early stage bioscience
companies and
and once we view what the science is all
about it's an incredible
possibility that's so complicated that
we say
we you know it's going to how do we get
that
yeah i love it it's just we're just not
there yet technology wise and you see
like even gene therapy you know 35 years
ago
gene therapy everyone was saying oh no i
don't know gene
yes gene therapy was around it was hard
to get it
get it past this stage here it's just
very complicated we're now in a
situation where the technology's there
the knowledge is there the the
understanding of disease
is much better um the capabilities are
much better the funding
is crazy uh so it's easy to get
something that's so
complicated figure out what you can do
to simplify it if you can't simplify it
then
then augment the delivery because of
what's available now from a technology
perspective
incredible and grow and i can't believe
20 minutes is almost up this went by way
too fast
uh but i do have to then ask you know
coming from an outsider's perspective
i'm thinking of biotech and you know
it's very difficult from somebody who
doesn't understand biotech in the
industry to really
understand the magnitude of what's
happening so maybe can you give me your
two cents of where do you see this
industry headed or what are some of the
most
important milestones that we will
achieve as humanity and as scientists
maybe in the next five or ten years that
we can hope to look forward to
sure i think one is that the diagnostic
rate is going to get much better for a
lot of different diseases
right now we have latent diseases that
people don't know about until it's
very severe or near near deadly so
um late diseases such as lung cancer
pancreatic cancer
ovarian cancer cancers where you don't
find it
until something's really wrong and the
patient knows
something's really wrong so i think that
that's one piece
i think another piece is obviously the
therapeutic side of it we have a lot of
diseases that we still don't completely
understand we're in the midst of a
disease right now
at least the virus yeah exactly but we
don't write we don't understand the
virus and therefore we don't completely
understand the disease that it causes
so you know i think that there's going
to be a lot of discovery there
i think that people will just become
more excited about science and in
medicine and i'm
really looking forward to that because i
think that the more people
you're a great example so you're saying
i don't really know that much about
biotech
after this 20 minutes my hope is that
you say wow i think i know something
about biotech now
and and i have the curiosity to now go
and examine further
well there's so much out there and so
much available to people it should not
be a black box so i think that that's
the third piece so i talked about the
diagnostics piece the therapeutic or the
cure
i think the third piece is that it's
time to demystify
biotechnology and that's a big big part
of what i do it's a big part of what i
do in industry but also what i do at
northeastern that
it's just it business is a process i
tell my my students that all time
business is a process you can demystify
it once you understand the different
components of business
biotech has a layer on top of that
because there are multiple functions
and regulations for good reason that
other industries don't have
but it's still a process it doesn't have
to be this unwieldy crazy
complicated process you just have to
know how they all fit together and how
they work so that you can get that
product
over to the patient so i think that's
the third piece that we're going to see
and one that i think is an imperative
and that is to demystify biotech it
sounds
really sci-fi it is really sad
you wouldn't believe what's going on in
industry right now but but there are
ways to make it very accessible
to to anybody out there who's interested
i just love your passion about this
krista before we leave i need three
words
that describe you best or three words
that you know your students or your
colleagues would describe you as
um passionate so that's what i get a lot
um i think the other p another word is
tenacious
so you know if i if something's worth
grabbing onto and and figuring out or
not letting go
until until it's been done i think
that's that's next piece
and uh or the next word and i i think
the third word is just
human you know i i highly regard my
humanness
my my faults my flaws my
happiness my enthusiasm that can
sometimes be too much
for people i know how to dial it down
but you know there's
i think there's a there's something to
be said
about about celebrating
your humanness whatever that might be
and it's part of what connects us all
together and it's part of what makes us
so unique as well so those are my three
words
i'm just so curious to see how you run a
board meeting from
these 20 minutes that's one thing that
i'm definitely curious about and
maybe one day we get to collaborate and
i'll be able to sit and on and file on
the wall and one of those
krista thank you so much for everything
thank you for the time
and i'm so excited to see where
everything is headed thank you
thank you be well thank you